(light playful music)
- Previously, when I was in IT,
I was in an environment
where we have computers
and air condition, and I, you know,
I have to dress up very well.
Now, look, I'm in the sea,
where, you know, you really feel one with nature.
My name is Malcolm Ong,
and I'm a fish farmer.
I started my career 21 years ago in IT,
but, actually, my love is in the sea.
I got to know many farmers,
and the farmers shared their
life with me, their passion,
and they influenced me,
and I decided that I
wanted to be a farmer.
When I entered into this
industry I thought to myself
that, "Hey, this is a opportunity to apply
"my engineering principles to farming."
For instance, when we bring in
fish fries from the hatchery
we have to count the fish
and also check the fish.
Now previously, all this was done
by estimation and by hand,
but now we use a camera system
to count the fish as they go past.
We can then also slow down the image,
and then we can check the fish, as well.
(water splashing)
I sell my fish to
supermarkets, wholesalers,
and restaurants in Singapore;
one of them is Candlenut,
which is a Michelin-star
restaurant in Singapore.
Our reputation is that we grow fish
in as natural a way as possible,
and that's why people like to buy from us.
When I first got into this industry,
nobody believed that we would make it,
but yet, we're able to come
in, and we made an impact.
And I hope that I set
an example for others,
so that they will be encouraged
to pursue their passion.